du livre hors du commun qu'est le voile
noir d'anny duperey aux éditions du
seuil
il est inconcevable de parler sans
précaution car si vous voulez bien me
croire vous allez en faire l'acquisition
est éprouvée l'un de ces chocs d'émotion
qui vous marque trop longtemps pour la
vie peut-être temps l'auteur a su
parlant d'elle-même s'adressait de la
façon la plus intime à chacun de ses
lecteurs
interprète tout de subtilité et
d'élégance de laclos et de jules renard
sur scène de stavisky d'alain resnais et
d'un éléphant ça trompe énormément
d'yves robert au cinéma anny duperey
avait jusqu'ici écrit deux romans
un jour elle s'est résolue à faire tirer
les négatifs de clichés pris par son
père photographe amateur follement doué
qui lui révèle qu'une enfance de
tendresse brisée par un drame sans
mesure
ses parents meurent asphyxiés un matin
de 1955 elle a 8 ans sa soeur six mois
c'est que nous ne guérit sont jamais de
la mort de nos parents nos enfants seuls
nous distrait de cette douleur intacte à
l'instar du fils d'annie duperey dont
elle dit si bien le profil sérieux
impénétrable merveilleuse figure du
grand père attentif de la grand-mère
l'yonne de la vie magnifique portrait
intemporel de l'auteur outre est fixé
une fois pour toutes par le noir et
blanc c'est la fin de ce livre d'amour
anny duperey peut écrire vous êtes mais
dieu mais dieu à moi et je n'ai fois
quand vous votre mort m'a rendu à jamais
enceinte de vous vous ma [ __ ] et je vous
aime